Nói đi xong đợi yêu ngoan
Thì mình nói đến một cái bài học
Là cái hức của cái màu yêu thế là em chó
Tưởng chá mẹ cơ em
Anh chỉ của cơ em
Vậy sao để cơ em
Một bài học
Mà có nè là mình khi nhận tay nền
Thì nó gợi yêu thế giới nhiều kìm đều
Một nha tay nền
Thì rất là quen
Nhưng
Vì yêu bà chức của sao đợi yêu ngoan là gì
Vì yêu bà
Vì bài quán
Chứ hiểu rau
Vì như thế giới rau
Vì đầu tiên phá phy yêu
Sao đợi là gì
Bà đợi là gì thì tao mình
Cói đi ra đúng yêu ngoan
Thì đi
Nè mà dí sao đâu là một chuyển là
Bói rửa chồng không ra
Là đi là là yêu là
Nhưng mà dí sao là là chuyển là
Nhưng mà chuyển là một có dí hả
Mà nó đi là là
Thì cái bây giờ rau rau gạnh thấy không lượng
Tình cây đúng như em xanh trái đúng như quà phy
Là đi là là gì là
Thì gió khổ thì cây đúng đưa thì
Đây là một giá là
Một nha mài kia gió mạnh quá
Gió rất là mạnh
Bà thôi
Một nha cạnh cây đúng cũng như thế giới không còn giang là yêu á
Một nha tà nói cạnh cây nó truyền là gì là
Dạ hồi lộn như quà bản chất là cái gì
Àa
Để mà
Thì cái em là ngồi bỏ em bỏ em bỏ em bỏ em
Cái em thấy chứ phào nó nhập ngôn lên xuống
Chứ mặc lưu
Vậy tà của để coi chứ phào nó ra hồi lập như quà